Here, the solution is 7 6ths, or 1 and 1 6th. Nice thinking if you found this
fraction. Basically, we're just going to evaluate our inverse function at x
equals 2. So we just plug in the value of 2, and for x. So 2 plus 5 equals 7.
And I still have 6 for my denominator. So 7 6ths or 1 and 1 6th. Now, there was
another way to solve this problem. If we remember that the x and y coordinates
switch for the inverse function, then we can make the y coordinate be 2. In
other words, we know the input for the inverse function would be 2. This means
that it must be a y value for the original function. So, we could take our
original function and let this output or this y value equal 2 and solve for x.
Letting this f of x equal 2, we can now solve for x. We'll have 6x equal to 7
and then we'll divide both sides by positive 6 to get x equals 7 6ths. Since x
is the input for the original function, we know this will be the output for our
inverse function. Remember that the x and y coordinates will always switch for
the function and it's inverse. Now, I know the second method is a lot longer
for finding our answer, since all we really needed to do was plug in 2 into
here. But it's worth conceptually noting, so that way we can understand that
the inverse and its function always have the x and y coordinates switched.